pour cette page était direction la saône
et loire et plus précisément la ville de
tournus tournus 6000 habitants sur les
bords de saône une ville connue pour sa
gastronomie ses restaurants étoilés mais
également pour son abbaye mais la ville
a d'autres atouts comme son hôtel dieu
musée greuze je vous propose de le
découvrir ça se passe par là si le mois
et l'on pénètre directement dans une
chapelle ouvrons sur trois salles
communes premières impressions ici le
temps semble s'être arrêté tout est
parfaitement conservés
c'est une fondation donc sur demande de
louis xiv qui voulait avoir des hôpitaux
généraux dans les villes pour soigner la
population caché également la misère des
villes avec l'accueil des mendiants dans
les hôtel dieu et puis plus tardivement
l'accueil des soldats également pour les
aider à récupérer de leur guerre et
surtout de leur traumatisme
on compte ainsi 53 lyon chaîne ils sont
aménagés d'une manière très précise
ici un et 18 lits de la salle des hommes
vous pouvez constater l'aménagement de
ce lit avec notamment la bastille noir
le traditionnel édredon rouge que l'on
retrouve dans les hôtel dieu et un
aménagement plus tardif avec cette corde
qui descend ici et surtout la porte qui
donne accès à la ruelle de service qui
est juste derrière moi et qui permettait
ainsi de donner des soins aux malades
avec un petit peu plus d'intimité
puisque l'on pouvait tirer les rideaux
qui sont à l'avant du lit cette rue elle
servait également pour sortir les corps
des personnes décédées en toute
discrétion et éviter ainsi des d'affoler
la population
autre particularité tous les lits sont
orientés vers la chapelle centrale car
aux xviie et xviiie siècles faute de
connaissances médicales poussées ont
tenté de soigner les corps à travers les
âmes via l'éducation religieuse mais les
soeurs bénéficie tout de même d'une
magnifique apothicairerie avec ses 150
poids faïence et ses 130 flacon de verre
un lieu magique pour les enfants surtout
qu'en regardant de près certaines
étiquettes interpelle comme le vinaigre
des 4 voleurs
cela remonte au moyen âge où
effectivement un voleur qui s'est fait
arrêter a expliqué que pour ne pas
tomber malade en allant dans des lieux
non recommandables eh bien ils sont
visés le corps du vinaigre des 4 voleurs
il inspirait également puisqu'il
enfreignait des linges qui elle
respirait et grâce à cela et bien ils
évitaient les puces porteuse de la teste
hôpital puis maison de retraite le lieu
a cessé son activité en 1990 quant au
bâtiment où vivaient les soeurs il
abrite aujourd'hui un musée dédié un
certain jean baptiste gruss
il a donné son nom au musée puisqu'il
est natif de la ville ailier né en 1725
à 30 ans il expose au salon à paris et
devient célèbre très rapidement en
france et ensuite dans l'europe entière
les gens s'arrachent ses tableaux dès
cette époque et vous avez ici son
portrait quand il devient célèbre à
l'âge de 30 ans il est très fier de
lui-même l'a toujours été sûr de son art
il se montre avec le portemine et il a
un air presque argo c'est ce qui sera
toute sa vie mais les gens adorent sonar
particularité il ne s'intéresse qu'à la
personne humaine à la psychologie des
gens et parmi toutes les oeuvres
présentées une se détache
particulièrement un pastel aujourd'hui
perdu de greuze qui furent produire
lithographie à l'époque du maître il
représente la philosophie endormi à
travers la belle batley boutiques et les
pousses de greuze elle est en haut elle
est assoupi là dans une superbe robe de
satin et avec un petit chien sur les
genoux et le petit chien symbolise
greuze donc son mari qui veille sur sa
maîtresse donc madame greuze et c'est
aussi les concours y ont vu un carlin
qui fait allusion à l'ordre des cas leur
carlingue est une obédience maçonnique
ordre dans lequel greuze et alia mélo
des graveurs vous rentrez l'année
suivante
c'est maintenant la fin de cette page
était consacré à l'hôtel-dieu musée
greuze j'espère que cette balade
découverte vous aura plu sachez que le
musée est ouvert tous les jours sauf le
mardi de 10h à 13h et de 14h à 18h à
bientôt